salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche et
c'est le jour des explications bien sûr
mais également de la fête des mères donc
bonne fête à toutes les mamans qui
regardent ces vidéos et plus
particulièrement à la mienne bonne fête
maman en fait c'est un piège que
j'entende à ma mère si jamais elle ne me
répond pas sur le fait que je vous ai
souhaité bonne fête dans cette vidéo
alors je serai qu'elle ne les regarde
pas tout
je suis l'obligent à les regarder en ce
jour particulier je me suis dit que ça
valait le coup de faire des choses un
peu particulière par exemple j'ai mis
une chemise au lieu d'un tee shirt comme
ça vous n'allez pas me dire qu'il est
par où passer aujourd'hui je vous
apprends un tour que vous allez pouvoir
faire à votre mère aujourd'hui alors
forcément à quelqu'un d'autre vous
pourrez toujours aussi le réadapter mais
j'ai vraiment pensé pour que ce soit un
tour spécial fête des mères que vous
puissiez faire facilement chez vous avec
pas grand chose et qui s'apprennent vite
c'est pas un tueur de mentalist est un
tour de magie est comme ça quelle que
soit vos moyens l'âge que vous avez le
temps que vous avez eue pour cette fête
des mères vous pouvez au moins offrir ce
tour-là à votre mère je vais vous faire
le tour pour vous faire voir ce que ça
donne vous prenez un jeu de cartes dans
vos mains et vous allez le confier à
votre mère donc je vais vous dire à quel
moment vous voulu passer le jeu vous lui
dites voilà que vous avez un tour à lui
faire pour son anniversaire et vous lui
dites voilà maman dans quelques secondes
tu vas prendre le jeu et tu vas te
donner les cartons du temps comme ça
vous lui tendez le jeu elle le prend et
vous continuez de lui expliquer qu'elle
dépose les cartes comme elle veut sur
l'état qu'elle veut elle peut en mettre
plusieurs ici un peu moins la même des
gros paquet là un petit peu là elle
alterne un petit peu comme elle veut et
elle donne tout le jeu comme ça dans
ceux qui se posent la question peu
importe si votre jeu de cartes est
complet ou pas attendre tout le monde
puisse réaliser le tour j'ai pensé à ça
aussi une fois que la distribution est
terminée en réalité ça va assez vite à
faire vous lui dites voilà ce qui se
passe maintenant tu prends le premier
temps et tu vas le séparer en deux comme
tout à l'heure en en mettant une à
gauche ni à droite ni à gauche ni à
droite ni à gauche ni à droite jusqu'à
temps qu'ils en aient pu mais ce coup ci
tu fais bien carte par kartcom ya pas
beaucoup de cartes savoir ce qu'il donne
à peu près je vous accélérerait la vidéo
pendant ce temps là vous pouvez vous
peut-être faire l'autre paquet puisqu'il
faudra le faire également sur l'autre
paquet ou alors vous lui demandez de
faire la même chose avec l'autre paquet
de ta supplémentaires en suivant la même
rêve
on a au final quatre t'as qu'a fait
votre mère voulu rappeler voilà tu as
donné les cartes comme tu voulais au
départ c'est toi qu'on était plus un
côté plus que de l'eau tout était
complètement aléatoire et pourtant si je
retourne maintenant la première carte de
chaque paquet ya marqué bonne fête des
mères alain bonne fête des mères est
maintenant je vous explique comment ce
tour fonctionne à leur départ j'ai
quatre cartes sur lesquelles j'ai collé
un petit post-it
je vais même scotché pour écrire le
message que je voulais faire passer
j'aurais pu aussi prendre des cartes
blanches mais comme c'est pas commun
tout le monde en a pas mais si vous avez
des cartes à double rouge et blanche de
l'autre côté vous pouvez écrire votre
message directement dessus et si vous
n'avez pas de post it pas chose comme ça
vous pouvez aussi écrire directement sur
les 4 as puisqu'il ya de la place sur le
faire moi ça se voit pas mais j'avais
pris les quatre dames donc vous réalisez
ça comme vous voulez on va faire ce
qu'on appelle un montage du jeu vous
prenez la première carte donc la bonne
vous la mettez face en bas dans vos
mains pour prenez la troisième carte
c'est à dire la mer vous la mettez dans
vos mains vous prenez la deuxième qu'a
donc fait des vous la mettez façon pas
encore sur le tas et enfin la dernière
carte au dessus et vous placer
l'ensemble cet ensemble des quatre
cartes sur le paquet ce qui vous donne
un paquet face en bas avec un nombre de
cartes alors que je sois complet ou pas
et les dernières cartes ias sur le
dessus sont bien bonne mère fait d emma
car tu es ma carte un peu décorés c'est
une décoration pour y en même temps si
vous regardez la vidéo sur les dessins
ce n'est pas surprenant
à partir de là le tour est quasiment
finie au tout départ moi j'ai fait un
mélange c'est un faux mélangent français
s'il ya des magiciens qui regarde voilà
je suis un faux mélangent français
d'ailleurs s'il ya des magiciens qui le
regardent j'aurai un petit truc pour
vous spécialement pour vous à la fin de
la vidéo c'est à dire après l'image de
faim après les autres ou sinon vous
sortez juste le jeu de l'étui et vous
dites voilà ce qu'on va faire on va
faire un tour
on lui fera voir l'exemple vous posez
les cartes comme ceux ci en alternant
gauche droite gauche droite
les quatre premières cartes donc les
quatre cartes de votre message qui va
passer d'un côté les deux premières
cartes du message de la côte et les deux
deuxièmes c'est pour ça qu'on les avait
alterné ensuite effectivement votre mère
fait vraiment ce qu'elle veut elle peut
mettre les cartes le nombre de cartes
qu'elle veut de chaque côté peu importe
combien même elle mettrait pas tout le
jeu ça n'aurait aucune espèce
d'importance bruit demandé ensuite de
reprendre les paquets de diviser car tu
pars car classe est important car tu
pars
carte les deux dernières cartes sont
forcément les deux cartes du message est
évidemment paris pour l'autre paquet
j'espère que ce petit tour adapté à la
fête des mères vous aura plu évidemment
vous pouvez le garder pour plus tard
comme unité pour faire apparaître autre
chose un autre message ou même ne pas
mettre le message et faire sortir les 4
as comme ça par quelqu'un moi ce que je
veux dire penser à réadapter en fait à
votre sauce comme vous voulez merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo spéciale
fête des mères si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en
laissant un petit coussin d'air
vous pouvez également cliquer là où pour
vous abonner à la chaîne car le mental
boxe et une vidéo par jour pour un âne
ont donc rendez vous de demain à 17h
ciao je vous donne une idée pour un tour
un petit peu similaire je vous
l'expliquais pas si vous avez les basins
magie vous suivrez vous comprendrez des
techniques employées
c'est vraiment pour vous donner une idée
supplémentaire
vous